not a single person has tape you have an
atomic bomb in your bag and if anybody's
gonna have tape it's you
i have to do everything you are wasting
a lot of time
welcome to your weekly ticket
gerard butler has signed on to reprise
his role as mike banning and knight has
fallen the fourth installment in the has
fallen action film franchise
butler will team up once again with rick
rominois who will serve as director on
the film
robert mark cammon who worked on angel
has fallen will return to write the
screenplay
it is currently unconfirmed if morgan
freeman who starred as president
trumbull in the first three films will
return for the fourth installment
deny guerrero will star as trailblazing
politician shirley chisholm in an
upcoming film the film titled fighting
shirley chisholm will portray the
titular figure during her 1972
presidential
run as the first black woman of a major
political party
to run for president of the united
states while guerrero will play chisholm
the movie is not a biopic and instead
will focus more on the campaign
and how the chisholm trail was populated
by young people
who sought social and political change
during one of the most turbulent times
in american history
and chris pratt will play star lord in
thor
love and thunder pratt will reprise his
guardians of the galaxy role in taika
waititi's upcoming
mcu film he joins a star-studded cast
which includes chris hemsworth as
thor and natalie portman who's returning
to her role as
jane foster they will also be joined by
tessa thompson and christian bale
the film is scheduled to kick off
shooting in australia this coming
january
in honor of the new mutants being
available to watch at home we're taking
a look at some of the best x-men films
and the future of the franchise under
disney stewardship with marvel studios
all right today we have none other than
comic book writer
creator of characters like deadpool
cable youngblood and
so many more rob liefeld here to help us
out
hey rob how's it going hey it's going
great thanks for having me
absolutely like so i'm gonna start you
off with a big question
yes what is the best x-men film
ever made so i was doing this and
separating them and
for me x-men two daisy future past
logan and first class are to me the best
of the crop like those are
really good movies i know that over time
it's just been group think or what i've
encountered as group think to just
think all the fox movies were no damn
good and that's just
no damn true there are some serious high
highs i believe achieved in those
movies i gotta go with my gut i still
believe
days of future past edges out the rest
there was a period i really thought
first class
had the most style and did more with
less but i think those are all upper
crust
best of movies you know days of future
past is my favorite comic book story
it's well chronicled in my career that
is my default
i own pages from that original arc from
that story and comics and i thought they
did a great job
with the film i thought it looked good
it had a great story it had a great
through line great performances
it was really cool the way they pulled
off merging the two casts
so that's my favorite days of future
past and then x-men two because x-men
two
is what x-men one would have been like
had they believed in it and given it
the budget it scaled up and it looked
phenomenal and let's not kid ourselves
how these movies look
and move and feel is always important so
well you take something like days of
future past and it
it does it borrows a lot from from the
comic but it isn't like
identical do you think no that's him
that's important what do you think is
the perfect balance
so that's a great question you know so
i'm in all these nerdy facebook
original art bronze age era because
that's my childhood okay
well i was 13 when i grabbed daisy
future pass
off the newsstand and turned the corner
at my market and there's wolverine older
protecting kitty pride the x-men are
dead okay so
as i was flipping through it the other
day i realized they made the right call
the beauty of the original story is we
as the reader
in real time had only been introduced to
kitty pride for
three issues and then suddenly she's
coming back as
she's a 40 year old lady or older as we
open it's way in the p
in the future and then she's sent back
to warn the
present day well the studio made the
right call shifting the entire movie
around hugh jackman
it works better if wolverine is the
consciousness that travels back
to warn us because we have no investment
as a paying audience
in kitty pride she was never developed
as well anywhere near
on screen so i mean that is the giant
perspective shift of the film is that it
takes place from
logan's point of view but yeah i think
the future past was a great um
merge of the two sensibilities the
younger
past cast and then the you know existing
and hugh jackman holds it all together
as he should making something with the
x-men you can really go
any direction you can do the comics you
can follow one singular character
there's so many different ways that you
can
apply the x-men so the mcu
is about to have to pick up that ball
and i'm sure
a lot of us have our own theories of how
we think that should happen
what do you think you know the fun part
about being old rob liefeld
is that i have teenage kids my one son
really
only ever got into comics on a limited
basis and
and they were dc comics um he really got
into green lantern
and and but he never kind of transferred
his love of he didn't love comics like
his dad did and obviously my daughter
doesn't and my younger son didn't
so they absorbed this stuff just on the
film and the tv level
into the spider verse comes out and
that's their first ever introduction to
anything
multiverse related and they accepted it
like
it was ice cream it was so easy to go
down the idea of
different iterations of all these
characters you know coming together
and to me that's what kicked open the
door for what we're seeing now as dc
prepares the flash movie right
and let's not kill ourselves these
companies watch each other what works in
one
is immediately implemented by the other
everyone watches each other i believe
because spider-verse worked
dc's like we're the kings of the
multiverse let's do this in in our new
flash movie
and we'll have michael cheaton and we'll
bring what happened to
spider-verse to life with actors you
know
and and call backs and it's exciting to
watch that stuff so as we
look at what one division which i'm
reading all about this morning
and then we know doctor strange is
coming and then we go back to
i think it's endgame or the ancient one
breaks down how the multiverse strands
work i gotta be honest
we're gonna look back at that i'm gonna
call it the lesson plan
that the ancient one gave an audience of
a hundred million people
as the primer for everything going
forward when it comes to deadpool
and that franchise the tag on deadpool 2
when he ha
i mean first of all you've got a time
traveler roland cable is a time traveler
i'm here to save the kid
okay you know and deadpool takes his
dial at the end right
and so and plays with it and ends the
green lantern franchise
right what do you want to see you've got
ideas i just can't wait to see him
interact with the x-men
break i can't wait to see the first time
he breaks the fourth wall in front of
other people or produces something out
of nowhere or
anything like that in a lot of ways you
know like would consume
all of these comic book movies it's so
good to see
him go in there and and play around with
that formula
um and you're right like ryan is he's
just fun to watch so
and i never know what to expect and i
love that like with other comic book
moves you can go and you can kind of get
an idea for where the story is going
well with deadpool
you know sometimes you just don't even
know you know would would i love to see
a scene
where deadpool is meeting with hemsworth
as thor
and rocket raccoon and then he pauses
and turns to us in the audience and
starts talking to us
breaking the fourth wall and thor goes
who are you talking to mate
[Laughter]
who's there well like you said that will
be the ultimate culmination
i mean people will explode i just can't
wait and i really appreciate you giving
us some
some insight some background what what
you would like to see
uh so thank you rob lightfield for
coming on the show yes let's go
multiverse
let's go multiverse option let's go
multiverse okay
thank you for so much for having me
thank you absolutely
available to watch in theaters is fat
man
[Music]
what's the job i'm lucky to kill santa
claus to save his declining business
kris kringle
also known as santa claus is forced into
a partnership with the us
military making matters worse chris gets
locked into a deadly battle of wits with
a highly skilled assassin
hired by a 12 year old after receiving a
lump of coal in his stocking
tis the season for fat man to get even
and available to watch at home is
dreamland
the thief and murderer allison wells
sent five human souls to heaven if you
see this woman
do not confront her margot robbie stars
in this love story set amidst america's
struggle during the great depression
eugene evans played by finn cole dreams
of escaping his small texas town
when he discovers a wounded fugitive
bank robber hiding closer than he could
ever imagine torn between claiming the
bounty for her capture and his growing
attraction to the criminal
nothing is as it seems and eugene must
make a decision that will forever affect
the lives of
everyone he's ever loved all right well
that's it for today but leave us a
comment and let us know
what is your favorite x-men film of all
time
i'm kale and i'll see you next time